so what are we doing here today we're
gonna do a waste characterization of all
of BuzzFeed's trash for a day for the
purpose of figuring out if there's any
opportunities to reduce waste maybe by
adding a recycling program or expanding
on your composting program so my goal is
that buzz feed reduces our total waste
by 20% do you think that's realistic I'm
gonna have to wait and see once we start
digging through the trash and see what
the opportunities are
[Music]
thank you guys all for volunteering
jonathan is our eco expert here and he's
going to be telling us what we're doing
so we're literally gonna be opening up
the bags of trash dumping it out and
trying to separate it the material by
type what are the different categories
we're gonna be sorting into we're just
gonna do some broad categories cardboard
mixed paper which would be like office
paper that sort of thing food waste food
soiled paper so maybe like napkins and
wrappers and then just kind of a general
category for other recyclables that we
don't need to specify anything else have
some fun we're just gonna start digging
in trash whoa any idea what we do with
these chip bags trash yeah trash cuz
they're really they're multi-layer
they're like metal on the inside of a
plastic film on the outside so that
these would actually be trash as well
and we call it solid waste unless it
says on it that's certified compostable
all these coffee cups have a plastic
liner on the inside so this is actually
trash what if we find batteries put them
aside like that should we go into
electronic waste I found a whole thing
of unopened meets that says drink soon
some paper towels as food soiled a food
so paper unless it came out of the
bathroom then we'll keep it separate hey
guys we got our first bagged away we got
a seven pound bag of trash we really
have 193 pounds ago the reason why we're
separating the food from the food soiled
paper is because for the purpose of you
guys expanding your composting program
that you have here you wouldn't want to
put any of the paper in it you'd want to
put only the food waste so I took out of
the bag a completely unused pile of
paper networks oh my god there's more
like we can actually reuse these
oh my god you guys throw away so many
aluminum cans in the trash and glass
bottles you hear that we found some
peril like members in the trash Jonathan
what is it made out of
it's like foam corner trash there
unfortunately go right in the trash
sorry
Pera like oh it's a heavy 120 pounds
this one is 9.6 pounds
we got a new amazing volunteer because
we had so much trash yeah Ryan's coming
to help out so when I was opening up
this bag I found inside it many bags of
just bagels that it looks like they're
on you slow one bag two bag three bag
let's see what look at another bag of
bagel oh my god
this is all the food ways so far Wow I'm
learning that we could do a lot better I
feel like people don't think about what
they're going away they just hop come on
oh thanks for coming do you want a hug
smells great right so all this trash is
just half of the trash that BuzzFeed
makes in one day oh it's good percent
[Applause]
[Music]
ari are you ready for the results of the
waste characterization yes you want to
guess what percentage of the trash was
actually trash 50% 36% so about 1/3 of
what's in the trash bin is actually
trash the other 2/3 are recycling or
compost
yikes I counted about a hundred pounds
worth of recycling a hundred forty
pounds of compost and about a hundred
thirty-five pounds of trash so my goal
of reducing all of BuzzFeed LA's trash
by 20% do you think that's possible it's
possible it might be hard to gather all
the recycling but if you were to recycle
all the bottles and cans that are being
thrown away and then add or expand on
the compost program to get all that food
waste out of the trash you could
definitely beat the 20% goal so I'm
gonna take you over to facilities to
have you present this information and
hopefully we can get all on the same
page and try to reduce some of the trash
we make here sounds great
ok thank you for meeting with us
basically we did a trash sort this
morning and Jonathan is gonna tell us
the results so about 2/3 of what was in
the trash bin is actually recyclable or
compostable 2/3 of it yeah about 2/3
shame but it's a great opportunity to
target some some of the item the big
hitters are a lot of bottles and cans
what can leave - yeah education it's the
first step is putting a recycle bin with
every trash can and then also labeling
specifically what items that are common
at BuzzFeed they can go in there I
haven't given up on my goal to reduce
our waste by 20%
to be working with facilities more to
make this happen I think it really
emphasizes to me like how much I should
be reducing and not just recycling it
made me realize that I need to be more
conscious as to where I put you know my
way specially the cans compared to other
waste characterizations and companies
you've done how bad is BuzzFeed you guys
have recycle bins so you're doing better
than a lot of businesses that still
don't have recycling at all